It's true. We're used to having him around all the time.
Maestro, he's solid as a rock just like me.
That's right. Nothing's gonna happen to him.
Sure. Here.
What a civilization.
What a way of doing things.
What a traffic jam.
What a spectacle.
Now, you take the Chinese.
They really knew how to...
Children, sorry.
Sorry to be late.
You see, I've been studying
You see, I've been studying the Chinese civilization.
And I was telling you...
No, I haven't told you anything yet, have I?
No, well, all this has made me a little bit late.
It couldn't be helped.
Traffic was at a snail's pace.
And it's cold enough to freeze icicles on an Eskimo.
The only way to warm my hands was to put them in my beard.
Maybe you wouldn't mind turning up the heat just a little.
And would you make me a nice hot cup of tea?
Thank you.
The Chinese, naturally, are a remarkable civilization.
Now, now, what shall we talk about today?
The Chinese?
Huh? Well, I mean, you, decide.
Some world-shaking problem.
The Earth and its future.
Ecology.
Huh?
Now, let's talk about Wild West.
Cowboys and Indians.
There, you see, that imaginary pistol?
Well, the Chinese are the ones who invented them
before anybody else did.
And gunpowder and cannons, and this cup is made of China.
Oh, yes, the Chinese made it 1,700 years before anyone else, and playing cards, and once again, it's the Chinese.
Five centuries ahead of the world.
I know what we'll talk about today.
Look at all the things around us, the whole wide world, the objects familiar to us.
Well, you know, it wasn't always like this.
No, here we are in a comfortable house.
We have artificial light whenever we want it central heating fortunately hot and cold running water the telephone
There's television and all the rest. We can't count them. We take them for granted
It has taken thousands of years and enormous effort and ingenuity of people everywhere to give us what we have today
So what do you say let's talk about all the great discoverers?
The great discoveries of mankind
We'll find out about all the people who helped create our world of today
and who are shaping the world of tomorrow.
Do we all agree, hmm?
Yeah!
Kenny, stick to cowboys.
Yeah, it really sounds boring.
Oh, no, no, you're not going to be bored.
I promise you.
Think of it, the story of human genius.
Boring!
It's the most exciting story ever told.
What would we be?
What would our world be like
if it weren't for the genius of the inventors and the discoverers?
Huh? You tell me that.
Maestro, what's this got to do with the Chinese?
Well, just as I was saying, the Chinese discovered everything long before all the others.
Well, almost everything.
Paper, playing cards, the decimal system, steam engines, the parachute...
Matches.
The compass.
How blood circulates.
All that, a thousand, two thousand years earlier than us.
And brandy as well.
That surprises you, doesn't it?
Yes, well, the mechanical clock.
Oh, yes, there it is.
Printing and rockets, the conveyor belt, suspension bridges, petroleum oil, and all that.
No one knows.
At best, not many.
So, you'll be one of the few in the know.
Maestro, there are many other inventors who are famous in history.
Archimedes, Gutenberg, Galileo, Pasteur, Edison, and plenty of others, right?
Yes, certainly, yes, to be sure.
I'll tell you what, let's see what the Chinese discovered this time and later we'll talk about all the others.
Yes?
Yeah, okay.
Now, let's take things in order. The very first inventors, in a way, were certainly the animals.
Birds, monkeys, but look at the birds.
Sometimes they got lucky, yes, but they had to know how to use their luck.
First tools, first weapons, and later on, as the large animals that provided food became increasingly rare,
man was to discover other ways of providing, and he turned to other food sources, and he discovered agriculture.
This stage of agriculture, let's go back to the Chinese.
As far back as the 6th century before our era, the Chinese were cultivating vegetables.
Intensive hoeing.
They had invented the iron plow, and a little later, the multiple row sewing machine.
New techniques that greatly increased crop yield, it took the West more than 2,000 years to adopt it.
2,000 years, do you realize?
The Gauls made barb of this strong drink the Chinese were drinking four centuries earlier.
Now, I'll bet you didn't know that, huh?
Now then, where was I?
In agriculture.
What's that?
Oh, yeah, agriculture.
Yes, well, this leads us right into the harness.
Would you believe, at that time in history, the traditional harness, withers type it's called,
well, straps went around the horse's throat and it could suffocate the poor ass.
But way back, a Chinese invented a draft harness.
A strap, a kind of a breast harness, went around the horse's chest.
And it didn't interfere with his breathing.
And then a bit later, the great-grandson of a Chinese gentleman who looks like me had another good idea.
The collar harness.
This one went around the shoulders.
was a real revolution. The same horse could now pull ten times the load. It took a thousand
years. A thousand years before the West managed to invent the collar harness. Now that I think
about it, we'd better discuss stirrups. How do you suppose people mounted horses before
there were stirrups? Well, okay. Some ways were ingenious. Some techniques were more
reliable stirrup. Now, the Egyptians didn't know him, the Greeks, nor the Romans. So how
do you suppose they managed to ride horses? Once again, back to China. Had to master the
art of melting metals. The Chinese were 2,000 years ahead. Stirrups was to change the face
of the earth. From the heart of Asia, invincible vast hordes set off on conquest. It was the
The Chinese stirrup set the stage of history for Western knights in armor.
Fantastic everything the Chinese invented.
None of it's true what he's telling us.
The Chinese invent all that.
I assure you, it's only the beginning.
There are so many things, imagine this.
The Chinese invented before anyone else did.
The compass, yes.
The magic lantern, though the forerunner of the movies.
The universal joint that makes car transmissions possible.
Hydraulic power, even the steam engine and water lock.
Paddle blade boats, the rudder.
No, in the 3rd century, 16 centuries before the West,
the Chinese discovered biological control of insects.
Yes, the ones that attack fruit are attacked by other insects.
One century, they invented.
Well, what they invented is really remarkable, even today.
A technique for salvaging sunken objects.
Later in the 20th century in the West, we're not doing much better in this.
It was in 1894 that for the first time a certain Baden-Powell was to fly, using a kite.
And inspired by the flight of birds, Otto Lilienthal opened the way to aviation.
But the first person to fly with a kite, and not entirely because he wanted to, was a young Chinese prince.
But let's begin at the beginning.
From the 5th century before our era, the Chinese had mastered kite flying.
History tells us that whenever a big Chinese city was under siege,
the people would fly kites to notify their distant friends that they were prisoners.
Shoot him down!
No, it's true.
But it's a nice story.
Now I'll tell you another story not so nice.
The emperor Gao Yang, he had his own way of setting his noble prisoners free.
Young Prince Yuan managed to fly quite a distance.
So he was the first man to fly 1,300 years before Baden-Powell.
Ah, yes. A while back, I spoke of bridges.
Now, let's talk about suspension bridges.
Everybody agrees. Eh, good, yes?
Eh, well, eh, they were invented where?
In China.
Hehehe.
This is the first suspension bridge.
Primitive, it's true, but how long ago was it?
Well, nobody knows exactly.
In any case, a bit later.
What are they doing?
What are they doing, huh?
Answer me that.
I'll tell you, it'll never hold.
The mainland bridge in Sichuan province
in the third century before our era.
It'll take the West 2,000 years to develop these techniques.
Take Europe only five centuries to attain this level of perfection.
Now let me tell you about the parachute.
It's generally believed that Leonardo da Vinci was the first to come up with the idea.
In fact, the parachute was invented centuries before our era.
This is the story of a young man who became emperor in the Zia dynasty.
But nearly 5,000 years ago, much later, approaching the year 1100...
What do we do?
and I didn't feel...
So what might this happen in the year 1080?
A year later,
Mr. Ambassador happened to be there and he wrote a full report.
Three years later, in Paris,
when the Montgolfier brothers were going up in their balloons,
an interested party found it...
Extraordinary!
Incredible!
At last, a man has flown.
But look here, Mr. Garnerin,
you don't mean you're planning to jump in mid-air.
Precisely, Mr. Montgolfier, precisely.
Fly, like a bird in the air.
A dream realized.
What the Chinese have done,
I can do better once I reach a height of seven or eight hundred meters in one of your balloons, then...
Then you will have the invention of the parachute in Europe, straight from China.
The very first example of writing was surely done on clay tablets in the Sumerian civilization some 6,000 years ago.
Later, the Egyptians used papyrus.
Paper was invented by the Chinese about the second century before our era,
and this paper was to have many surprising uses.
Paper. Watch.
Paper.
and once again paper your fire wore off but we'll trade your paper armor for our metal armor
agree why do you want to trade your armor is as resistant as ours and they're quite a bit
lighter than ours are they'll be excellent for the conquest i'm preparing so is it agreed
let's go all of you off with your armor 10 paper money was introduced in china
See that? It's only paper we want!
Sure, sure, we're gonna get rich, yeah, sure.
Counterfeiting is punishable by death.
It was only in the 13th century that paper was to be made in Europe.
15 centuries after China and paper money didn't appear until the 17th century.
868, the first book to be printed on paper, the Sutra of the Diamond, a sacred text.
1041, a Chinese Picheng invents movable type, 26 characters in the West, up to 400,000 in China.
And then came the Mongol conquests, right to the borders of the Germanic Empire.
Where, and what a surprise, the printing press is soon reinvented.
But the inventions of our Chinese friends weren't always positive.
They were rifles, and mortars, and cannons, incendiary missiles, even flamethrowers.
That's right, but even then they showed great imagination.
And gunpowder.
While alchemists were trying to create an elixir of life,
they invented a way to shorten the lives of millions.
Yes, gunpowder.
And rockets created to celebrate festive occasions.
Maybe it's a part of our nature to turn what is meant to be useful
and bring joy into something that kills.
Just a few more centuries and rockets find their way to the west.
But it doesn't have to be this way.
No new inventions can and must contribute to the progress of mankind, not aggression or domination of others.
If the desire is there, men and women can be useful, kind-hearted, and maybe even inspired.